Пане Саакашвілі, як саме та хто Вам запропонував
посаду віце-прем’єра в уряді України?
Спочатку президент Зеленський,
а потім я мав бесіду
на цю тему з чинним прем’єром
Денисом Шмигалем.
Чи було це для Вас неочікуваним?
Розмови про це велися довго.
Це не було неочікуваним,
тому що було багато людей,
які в різних формах
пропонували інтегрувати мене
в цю вертикаль влади.
Але, я думаю, вже те, що
президент пішов на цей рішучий крок,
він продемонстрував сміливість,
коли це пропонував.
Я довго не думав, тому що вважаю,
що зараз дуже критичний час для країни.
Ми тільки на початку дуже великої кризи,
яка нині насувається на Україну,
яка буде просто реально
шкодити кожному українцю.
І нам треба якось оборону вибудовувати
для того, щоб захиститися.
Посада віце-прем’єра була єдиною пропозицією?
Чи Вам запропонували з чогось обирати?
Я думаю, що різні варіанти розглядалися.
Але те, що була тільки
ця пропозиція, - це так.
Так що я взагалі не просив,
не наполягав на чомусь.
Більше це було в нас порозумінням.
Ми довго вже спілкуємося,
багато місяців з президентом Зеленським.
І з усіх питань
у нас є майже 100 відсотків порозуміння,
і тому я  хочу його підтримати.
Чому Ви погодилися на цю пропозицію?
Я вважаю, що зараз необхідно було погодитися.
Тому що дуже велика криза тільки починається.
Українська економіка може впасти десь більше,
ніж на 10 відсотків
загального національного продукту.
Це означає, що
мільйони українців залишаться без роботи.
І цей процес уже почався,
в нас буде велика кількість людей, які будуть просто
в такому стані, що вони будуть протестувати.
І це буде зрозуміло, чому так відбувається.
Більше того,
реальні прибутки українців
скоротяться більш ніж на 20,
а може й більше відсотків.
У нас нині дуже складні перемовини з МВФ.
То я вважаю, що в такій ситуації треба прискорювати реформи.
Криза - це великий виклик.
Але це є також і велика можливість,
якщо правильно цим користуватися.
Свого часу я вивів Грузію зі світової економічної кризи
з найменшою шкодою в цьому регіоні.
Може, і зараз вдасться.
Так, у мене є досвід, як це робити.
Звісно, інша ситуація, вона  змінилася,
але базовий рецепт залишається таким самим.
Я буду ділитися своїм досвідом.
І досвідом досягнень, і досвідом помилок
тому що помилки також були.
Які реформи Ви реально можете втілити нині,
за умов викликаної
пандемією коронавірусу кризи?
Ну, вірус це інша справа.
Я сподіваюся, що якесь полегшення почнеться.
Але я намагаюся працювати в двох сферах.
Перше - це контакти і інтеграція
з міжнародною спільнотою,
це стосується і МВФ, і Світового банку.
В мене великий досвід цих стосунків.
Дуже позитивний.
З іншого боку, це дерегуляція.
Це звільнення українського бізнесу від адміністративного тиску.
Це моя мрія впродовж багатьох років цим займатися в Україні.
Я вважаю, що якщо ми звільнимо український бізнес,
це відкриє абсолютно нові можливості для
великої кількості українців і взагалі - для цілого регіону.
Тобто, для мене це такі професійні
і виклики, і можливості.
І можливість показати, на що я здатний.
Також і така амбіція є, щоб показати,
що в конкретній галузі для конкретних людей
можна зробити щось корисне
і до цього прикласти руку.
І тому, коли  президент запропонував,
я довго не думав,
тому що я хотів це робити.
Тобто Вам поставили завдання все ж таки?
- Ні.
- Що Вам треба зробити на цій посаді?
Коли ми обговорювали,
то якраз говорили про такі речі.
В мене немає амбіцій усім одразу займатися.
Посада віце-прем’єра обмежена певними функціями.
Це реально висока політична посада,
але також фактично цей міністр без портфеля.
І це означає, що треба мати конкретну функцію,
конкретне повноваження від прем’єра і від президента.
Чотири роки тому Ви пішли з посади
губернатора Одеського регіону.
І одна з причин була те,
що рівень корупції в Одеському регіоні був настільки високим,
що неможливо було взагалі цю корупцію подолати.
Чому Ви наразі знову вирішили повернутися?
Адже ситуація з корупцією не набагато поліпшилася?
Тому що я вважаю, що
Порошенко особисто був частиною
і очолював системну корупцію.
Я абсолютно переконаний, що президент Зеленський
нічого спільного з корупцією
не має і не буде мати.
Він особисто проти цієї системи.
І зараз вирішується питання,
або він подолає цю систему,
або система знищить його
і всі ці нові починання, з якими
українці пов’язують надію на своє майбутнє.
От і все. Дуже просто.
Нещодавно Ви заявляли, що Україна може розпастися на п’ять частин…
Ні. Я цього не казав.
Я казав, що це мрія нашого ворога.
Але якщо Україна не проведе реформи,
якщо Україна не зміцниться економічно,
якщо Україна не буде також приймати всі заходи проти сепаратизму,
то, звісно, план нашого ворога може і здійснитися.
Це абсолютно не тільки катастрофічний сценарій для України або для Грузії,
а й катастрофічний сценарій для світу.
І ми всі маємо не допустити, щоб це сталося.
Я впевнений, що якщо ми все правильно зробимо,
то ворог не зможе втілити
в життя цей сценарій.